well the IMF statement is very very
serious and it comes on the back of what
the bank of England said earlier this
week and I think for so many people
looking at their mortgage payments this
morning worried about whether they can
now afford to pay them and for prices
um they will be not just frustrated but
angry because the government has lost
control of the economy sometimes when
the pound Falls it's because of external
factors International factors this is
self-inflicted this is a government that
on Friday took the Reckless action which
lost control of the economy and for what
to cut taxes for those who are earning
hundreds of thousands of pounds and now
so many working people across the
country are facing trouble with their
mortgages trouble with their prices so
this is really serious what I want the
government to do is to set out a plan as
to how they're going to fix the problems
that they have created not wait till
November which is what they're
suggesting review the decision they took
on Friday I'm bringing the obr for
stability because this is all about
confidence and what this is telling us
is that the markets have no confidence
in what this government is doing with
their economy you said your party would
be would balance the books would be the
party of sound money but you've also
said that you would keep some of the tax
cards the income tax cut for example
that the government announced if you win
the next election and you find you can't
balance the books will you have to
reassess some of that we've set out very
clear fiscal rules which is we will pay
for day-to-day spending we will only
borrow to invest we've also been equally
clear that we would reverse the tax cut
for those earning hundreds of thousands
of pounds we think that's the wrong
thing to do we wouldn't cut corporation
tax we don't think that's the right
thing to do and businesses aren't asking
for it would have a windfall tax on oil
and gas companies who've made excess
profit so those are the decisions that
we would make we would have clear fiscal
rules contrast that with the government
broken every fiscal rule it's ever had
lost control of the economy and this
government could never again claim to be
a government of fiscal responsibility